hello and welcome to this video Yardbird
again yeah recent games I didn't score
so badly I feel I'm still quite behind
at the same opening with black last game
I with white I'm sorry 33 losses 2727
win seven drawers very low if you draw
right against the output
yeah Black is happy that he has gotten
rid of his LightSquared bishop and in
general blacks position is very very
solid so this is probably white serving
the best try against the bt7 against the
bt7 variation I never thought that it
leads to much but it's just what it is
this line is very very hard to hard to
break down okay so if I of quite often
is so is an idea night efore also comes
into consideration okay let's do this
first bishop to c7 and also stand that
idea
now White's ideas to maybe try to play
against a c6 pawn Queen invading 93-95
this is the this is the point the idea
I had it yeah and still hard to not do
it now it was what I had prepared check
I don't like it hmm I shouldn't I should
have played that difficulty already we
got regret my decision
Jeff not comfortable not be 395 it's
pretty simple simple plan
I can cover that with 98 which is like
the most passive move ever on maybe
night GA 97 looks a bit better okay
now I don't think this event is this
leads to much
I think the end game should be ok mean
the invaded queeny's is the issue
I will play Queen see a door nope tools
for the ending hey it's still it's still
slightly more comfortable for Wyatt
would I don't know do I go to a six-year
oh is that is that a bad idea can also
try to grab a little bit of space I mean
he could try now I don't believe it to
sacrifice a piece
a chance to go to the eighth okay can I
do something active with my night here
hmm it's a bit tough to get rid of his
night maybe saw this he wants to come to
23 I night let this badly I shoot it
wasn't necessary at all
absolutely unnecessary
last laughter that can hang one there
for a bit but it's he could improve his
nitrile a 2 2 d 3 and how stupid can you
play him it was I'm one entirely
unnecessary
quite I'm not quite sure if it's doing
this correctly I'll just see if I can do
something with my own pawns check check
okay check here we go I don't know can I
win this currently I'm keeping this
covered so I can try to promote here
immediately however I cannot probably
maybe this one now check this could
still be a chance to win yeah white
resign yeah is a win is a win Wow tough
game
he has an auto thank you and now they
won't have to reply the games are always
cool i mean it's it's it's really tough
usually he shows wise the better player
but sometimes i can i can fight back
okay yeah i mean i was worse but somehow
yeah held on I just play that I've just
played that in a stupid way I mean here
I'm slightly worse as it happens in this
position or in this opening sometimes
nothing dramatic just a little bit but I
think I made a couple of inaccurate
moves maybe already this is not quite
necessary I could have started with this
is the bishop maneuver I mean this is
getting slightly uncomfortable but I
think after the green trade I shouldn't
I shouldn't get into this trouble I
really shouldn't ah i can go ahead as
the damn computer it immediately shows
this and it's it's immediately clear
that i'm out of the woods now yeah the
ID i have no problem at all i can even
put my night here and he cannot open up
the position anymore I mean it's just
it's a draw but it is a draw i am
nothing to fear I can't hear I still
think I should be okay but I'm playing
there I'm playing this this not not well
here here should just stay don't do
anything the computer suggestion is
always again interesting it wants to
play this
very nice 49 f5 check this is the idea
now a very good idea yeah and this was a
bad idea it is just an awful move I was
actually getting ambitious yeah thinking
okay maybe Nations is wrong I covering
this and I wanted to move here and push
the night back but ok now he just gets
the night to d3 and this is here this is
certainly critical I'm definitely in
some in some danger here if not losing
ok now the computer shows a loss this is
this is winning for white but why this
is synthesis better and then taking away
the King okay that just wins the porn
okay but I felt I will still lose him
yeah this is maybe the issue you form
night sea change now
hmm suks 1 i've been some kind of zoosk
lucky oye mini as this I was very lucky
win tis still 98 wins and this losses
yeah it was just someone chef Chad one
more sometimes but I wondered here
probably I could have done this I just
King c3 and to march the pawns I went
here before it but I hope that will yeah
i saw that correctly the sisters win the
Janus polyester porn is unstoppable ok
tough game in very lucky wondering ok I
can maybe claim I defended tenaciously
but he should have gotten the win in
this game ok thanks for watching